foreign
yes I'm an acute Observer uh
airplanes air traffic
airports
all of it
I just think okay it's one of the Great
beautiful things
of civilization that we can fly and I
bet if you've ever seen a 747 take off
you're thinking yourself oh my gosh
right the 300 ton hunk of aluminum or
however much it weighs right it flies
the thing flies and it looks like it's
in slow motion when it's flying that's
even more it does stunning amazing
amazing I just wanted to update you on
some things that have happened slowly
that you might not have noticed
okay all right so
airplanes today
when they leave the runway
typically take off at a steeper angle
into the air than they once did many
decades ago what that does is
reduce the acoustic footprint
of the airport so that the sound is not
disrupting whatever's going on on the
ground so you can sell real estate
closer to the airport without the
airport badly influencing those real
estate values
oh so that's one little thing that has
changed over the years okay and people
hardly are thinking about it but I'm
putting it out there okay the engines
are more powerful to enable that
not only that the engines are quieter
than they ever were
when I grew up and I'm not that much
older than you Chuck this would have
overlapped some of your day
if a plane flew overhead
you had to stop your conversation let
the plane continue flying and then you
continued your conversation you could
not speak over the sound of the engines
if a plane was flying overhead
now are you sure you didn't grow up next
door to an airport
because that could have been the problem
I distinctly remember this okay I
remember filming in the 1990s in my
early days of getting filmed for
documentaries and television we had to
stop every time a plane was flying over
because it made noise and it showed up
in the microphone now you barely know we
still do that today though they still do
that barely is what I'm saying yeah hey
there's a plane you're not saying you're
not distracted by the sound of the plane
well no sound guys are are kind of
primadonna's you know what I mean they
went they want their pristine sound so
they'll stop production they'll stop
production even for even for that I
can't impress upon you how much quieter
jet engines are relative to even just a
few decades ago okay did you know that
in 1969 when the Mets were in the World
Series
mayor Lindsay
redirected traffic from LaGuardia to not
fly over the stadium because when planes
Flew Over The Stadium everything stopped
the announcers couldn't speak
I remember this that's how old I am okay
I'm just saying
that's pretty damn loud now that anytime
a roaring a stadium full of roaring
people can be drowned out by a plane
correct LaGuardia is very very
announcers cannot hear each other under
the under the under the play so that's
an example of course that's insane than
over the city but still is my point okay
so that's wild that's other little
things you might not have noticed planes
no longer Taxi
okay in the old days okay Fly to Your
City oh there's not a slot for you and
you just circled oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I didn't realize that they called
that taxi it's called taxi you'd go in
taxi yeah they put you in a holding
pattern you go around the area and
around the airport until you had a place
to land okay no longer okay you know why
take off 10 minutes from now instead of
now so that we can land you when you
arrive at our city
that is how precise the calculations are
with wind speed airplane speed uh uh
jury all of that all of that now you
might still want I mean unless unless
it's Spirit let's be honest
if it's Spirit Airlines yeah they don't
have it they don't have that technology
yet okay
um so that doesn't happen because
computers calculate your your takeoff
time and Landing time and landing
position yes thing change but I'm saying
overall
no we're not burning gas waiting to land
in the way that once was a routine fact
okay that's a that's an advance and it
happens slowly and we're there I I don't
know who did that but somebody got a
really nice raise because you want to
talk about saving probably upwards of
like close to a billion dollars in fuel
costs it's huge it's huge it's huge yeah
it's got it's insane that's amazing so
there's that okay and then we talked
about on a different explainer those
little upturn flaps up turn the end of
the end of the Wings okay that was an
engineering an aerodynamic engineering
Advance discovered at NASA
because the first a in NASA stands for
what
they're not Aeronautics National
Aeronautics and Space Administration so
aeronox is a piece of NASA funding
congressionally mandated and so they
discovered this and you save anywhere
between five and fifteen percent fuel
efficiency from these exercises
that's right it changes the the the drag
on the wingtip and makes it more smooth
and laminar and then it could so that's
another Advance here's another one all
right
um when was the last time you saw
someone throw up on an airplane
um well you know every time I fly okay
except for you
no here's the point here's the point
there was a day when it was the duty of
the pilot to sort of do what they can as
they fly it to maintain the stability
and you'd have turbulence and things
like that there are control surfaces on
the airplane controlled by computers
that make micro adjustments in the flaps
that maintain a level of stability the
likes of which planes have never seen
before
I know yeah yeah and so that's funny
it's funny you say that because the last
time I flew which was very very short
time ago
um I was sitting in the chair thinking
God it is almost peaceful up here this
is so this is my point okay and and yes
you might have had a nice little pocket
of area you're trying to but my point is
yeah and they say uh when you everyone
to return to the seats since parking lot
we're going to go through some
turbulence and it's just a little bit of
jiggly yeah exactly they say that wasn't
nothing that you know that was that and
so you know we've Advanced when that's
what they're warning you about okay and
so so plus we have very good weather uh
mappings of turbulent Eddies in the
atmosphere and they know to avoid them
to go under them around them that's
that's right okay okay so
we also have what is basically Precision
weather forecasting
right when I was a kid you look at the
weather forecast and all you want to
know is is it going to rain tomorrow
uh they say 50 chance of it's all you
that's okay and by the way if someone
says there's a 50 chance of something
happening in the weather it means they
don't know anything
think about it no okay flip a coin flip
a coin I can flip a coin I don't need to
pay you to calculate that anything is a
50 chance of anything okay that's pretty
funny yeah yeah so uh but week on your
app now on your smart on your on your uh
smartphone you can dial up the forecast
and it'll say it'll continue raining for
the next 25 26 minutes and then it'll
stop and sure enough to the minute it's
accurate for where you're standing all
right and so this is a Triumph of
weather forecasting that spills into the
ability to guide airplanes where and
when you need them to reduce the risk of
encountering very bad weather but that's
not my favorite part of this of this the
airplanes my favorite part is again okay
I might have said this in another
because I don't this all just jumbles in
my head here it is you ready
um
have you ridden modern roller coasters
lately
oh yeah so modern roller coaster it's
not you're you're not in a in a cart
with with it
you're this you're actually in in an
open airtight cockpit with just a
harness over the top of you that's
basically dangling there okay and when
the thing makes the turn
your your Gondola swings out swings out
make that turn have you ever do you ever
noticed that okay oh yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah well what's going on there oh well
at the speed you're going
and the radius of curvature of that turn
the free-floating uh Gondola whatever
you want to call this thing you're in
will swing out to the precise angle
where your effective gravity is still
into your pants into your seat
oh okay okay I mean all right okay this
is important okay so you're tipped at an
angle but you don't feel the angle
because the combination of gravity and
centrifugal force is such that you your
up or down is still straight into your
seat and up above your head right even
if that's
okay that's true on an airplane they
solve that equation
they solve that equation on an airplane
so when the airplane Banks a turn
it does it at the speed and the bank
angle such that you don't even know
you're turning
because everything is just vertical to
you you can have a glass of wine sitting
there and the level of the liquid is
perfectly horizontal to you and to the
sides of the glass yet you open the
window to the left right and the ground
is down here and the clouds are up there
and then it does this and the ground is
down there and the clouds are up there
and your liquid in your glass of water
wine or vodka is completely level the
computer does that computers know how to
combine that so you don't even know
you're turning and so no longer do you
lean into one way or another when the
when the plane is banking so this adds
to the stability of your entire uh uh
plane flying experience
that's what I'm saying this is very cool
um what I am uh gaining from this
discussion
is
a brand new appreciation for computers
okay
[Laughter]
okay it's really that cool it's
a shooters that are cool man figuring
all this out to give you the same ride
smooth ride quieter ride less you know
so awesome so the way to do this is try
to get the people to your left and to
your right to oh oh when you're nearing
the airport
um because when you're more likely to
turn to line up for the runway have both
sides lift up their their windows and
put a glass of water right in front of
you okay if you can still have it at
that unless yeah they're not taking it
okay but yeah it's right in front of it
then again wait a minute I forgot you
fly first class so you still you still
might be able to get a glass of water
okay okay so I'm just letting you know
just watch the level around the rim and
then look to the left and right and as
the plane turns nothing happens to that
water level even though the plane is
tilting to bank the turn that it needs
to come in for Atlantic this is a this
is this is a by the way you do this in a
physics class you can ask what is the
speed this is how you determine what the
bank of a track is all right if you're
going to bank a track for something you
know is going 150 miles an hour
then you can know what bank and what
radius of curvature and all those
numbers come together so that
if you're in the car you don't feel
yourself being pushed to the left or
right so this is all on airplanes I mean
it's I love airplanes they're brilliant
in beautiful things
I I listen I I I I I don't disagree I
just love computers more now that's all
I think I'll tell you something else one
last thing here before we land This
Plane see what I did there so there was
a day when computers were still new you
know and I run at computers from the
beginning that's how old I am but when
when they finally reached the public
there was an old saying they say to air
is human
to really foul things up requires a
computer
well in the day yeah you'd make a
mistake but a computer will make the
mistake a thousand times before you call
it right in that mindset they asked
people
um
do you want a computer flying your
airplane
suppose something happens to the
airplane and something bad happens and
and you have to land the airplane who do
you want what do you want to land the
airplane a computer
or a trained Navy pilot okay and almost
everybody said a trained Navy pilot but
I was early out of the box and I said
the computer I say
but back then that might have been a
controversial answer today the computer
is already doing it all right and yeah
practically for show all right because
you know Kyle is there to make you feel
good yeah that's uh I think they want to
engage you know just because they
they're trained and you don't want to
you know you don't want to seed
everything to a computer but there was
talk and I was on a White House
Commission that discussed this in the
future this after 9 11. you say if a
plane is hijacked what do you do
and we we had the ability then we
certainly have it now to lock out the
entire control panel of the cockpit
and land the plane from the ground
that's uh why don't we have this already
it's nothing you there's no button you
can push in that car pick that'll do a
damn thing correct it's 2023 an air
Odyssey you know it's just like I'm
sorry I can't do that Mr terrorist
that's that simple just let the pilots
get up there hey you want this you got
it bro hey I'm going to Bath you know
what I mean we give up it's all yours
you know and then the computer just goes
you know oh I'm sorry I wish I could
help you man you know
that's great yeah that is a that's
brilliant and you know you're living in
the future when you you enter this you
know 150 ton tube of metal and sit in a
comfortable chair be served drinks by
someone whose job in part is to make
your trip comfortable have access to
hundreds of feature-length movies
surf the Internet eat a hot meal a pasta
marinara with it with a alcoholic drink
land safely four hours later
greet your loved ones and say uh the
marinara was salty
yeah that's your biggest complaint
you're living in the future
yeah that's for sure some Airline is
going to try to tap you to be a
spokesperson bro I'm letting you know
that right now so United American
somebody's coming after you JetBlue
it won't it won't it won't be spirit
because you you know everything you just
said none of that happens
one Spirit none of what you just said
happens you know so all right that that
was our tour uh uh airplane updates
all right a check always good to have
you there's another always a pleasure
explainer first start talk you'll
deGrasse Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist
foreign
[Music]